super ami parent ami super amis donc
plus de taxes pendant pendant six mois
d'autres villes l'ont fait mais dijon
l'a fait tout de suite on travaille la
main dans la main avec shopping dijon et
et ça il faut le savoir
là ces pme c'est à dire l'ensemble des
petites et moyennes entreprises la
confédération elle est à nos côtés et
elle remercie la ville pour tout ce qu
on fait
aujourd'hui il ya une aspiration de
nouveau à vous commerciaux proximité il
faut qu'elle télé c'est le sud et dans
l'immédiat compte tenu de la crise et
considère qu'elle assure commerçants sur
les cafés les restaurants
il faut des mesures proposées loupé un
exemple une exonération des droits de
voirie et de deux terrasses est enseigne
toutes les logements seulement juste
mais franchement la crise sanitaire avec
les deux mois de confinement ont prouvé
tout l'intérêt des commerces de
proximité pour le service à la
population dans tous les quartiers
disions il ya eu la chance encore
d'avoir des pointes des commerces de
proximité
donc il faut continuer à aider ces
commerçants encore une fois le fait de
piétonniser de d'embellir que ce soit
vers le centre-ville où les quartiers
niveau avec des commerces de proximité
c'est une réponse aux commerçants et aux
artisans